[Music]
boy everyone either poo character got
the wrong movie take herb eglee
Christopher Robin even the goddamn hell
level up somehow got its own movie they
had to actually make two movies called
Winnie the Pooh just to remind you who
the main character is well nevertheless
we're gonna look at the taker movie
today the bouncy bouncy charming
character that gives us an almost bouncy
bouncy charming movie Tigger as you
probably have guessed is bouncing all
throughout the Hundred Acre Wood kind of
annoying his friends but kind of
delighting his friends but one day he
realizes being the only one can be well
kind of lonely so he decides to look for
more tickers and after talking to all he
says that he has to find his family tree
he takes this quite literally and go
searching through the woods to find an
actual family tree ruins him as well as
his other friends but quickly they
figure out there is no tree to be found
feeling bad root decides to get
everybody together to write him a letter
from his family a family of tickers that
doesn't exist but still show their
support
ticker gets so excited at this letter
and somehow confuses that they're going
to come over the following day this of
course puts his friends in a predicament
and they have to figure out whether or
not they tell Tigger that the family
isn't real or they have to pretend to be
his family do you can guess which one
they pick okay so this movie is not
particularly strong in story but none of
the Winnie the Pooh movies are supposed
to be they're supposed to be simple and
story but emotionally heavy the problems
and dilemmas are not the big focus the
big focus is how it impacts the
characters and how they work off each
other and how their different
personalities can for lack of a better
way of putting it bounce off each other
and for the most part we get that along
with some really great animation then
not only surprisingly does the facial
expressions very emotionally I mean
there's only two dot eyes and yet
somehow they get across so much emotion
but also in that old-school sketchiness
you can't look at the line work and it
looks like something almost out of the
book look at all the lines on Tigger no
two stripes are the same they're all so
sketchy and seems so alive somehow the
backgrounds are also phenomenal I
watched this and fallen I'm so glad I
did because this takes place in fall and
winter and good lord they're so gorgeous
it's a different kind of Disney
background that you don't really see at
that time when
we're doing anime and movies maybe you
saw a little bit lilo and stitch with
the watercolor but you'd never saw this
kind of style it's very simple but very
beautiful and very atmospheric which is
what I think when Eva poo is things
start to go downhill both figuratively
and literally in the third act I won't
go too much in the spoilers but as you
would probably guess this is a liar
revealed story where somebody keeps a
secret from somebody to keep them happy
but then the person finds out they get
really angry can't accept that the
people we're doing it for a good reason
can only see that they lied and then
they go and try to get into even more
trouble or do something really stupid
and the friends have to go and help in
somewhere there's an understanding about
how everybody is happy again it's so
rare that these stories work because
they rarely add anything else that's the
drama the drama that we've seen a
million times and is tired and cliche
and sadly this is kind of the same thing
not only boring and cliche but it does
stuff I feel like the Winnie the Pooh
universe doesn't really do the climax of
the movie yeah there's a climax problem
number one has to deal with them
outrunning an avalanche and not falling
off a cliff
the original ends with them just walking
across a creek that's more what these
stories were about not how we gonna get
off of this rock while we're falling to
our deaths it just feels so phony and
forced almost as forced as Jerry
Springer references and Marilyn Monroe
references and yes sometimes they really
missed the mark with this but for at
least two-thirds of the movie they're
right on target they once again bring
back the Sherman Brothers to do the
songs and they're fantastic well most of
them there's a bluesy one that's a
little weird but the others are hummable
have brilliant lyrics and they're just
it's the Sherman Brothers I just love
hearing their stuff the characters as
well are still incredibly charming too I
don't know why they've never botched up
these characters when the poo is too way
the poo taker is still Tigger piglet Oh
piglet
maybe because the idea is to keep them
so simple they don't really need to add
that much and that's exactly what they
do if they just let them be themselves
and they are just so likeable which just
makes it all the more shameful when you
see it works - such a cliche climax even
the message of the movie you can figure
out very early on and yet it still waits
until the very end
to reveal it but again I really have to
give credit to the things that did right
you never do see the Tigger family which
I think would have done a mistake they
do still keep the majority of it very
simple and they still nail these
characters perfectly so yeah if you're
looking for something that's not
especially big and epic except what it
tries to be big and epic and that comes
across as kind of awkward this is a very
nice charming simple movie which is what
I think most people are looking for when
they see it Winnie the Pooh movie I
don't think it's among one of the
greater Winnie the Pooh movies but I
still think it's worth checking out
bounce on in and take a look
[Music]